dans l'affaire des disparus de Lyonne le
suspect numéro 1 a avoué le meurtre des
SEP jeunes filles disparues entre 77 et
79 le témoin numéro 1 vient d'être
transféré à oser après avoir été entendu
par les gendarmes de
dragignon et mais lou était bien
pratique puceque on faisait que parler
de lui c'était un fait d'hiver du coup
on a notre sérial killer et puis voilà
après c'est
plié mais il aurait jamais pu agir de la
sorte s'il n'avait euh pas bénéficier
bah de la permission en fait c'est c'est
pas seulement des protections en fait
c'est tiens vas-y vas-y papi sers-toi
puis comme ça si on a un problème un
jour de toute façon il y a papi qui est
là c'est lui qui sera pris dans la pièce
où on a ouvert la porte quoi voilà et
c'est exactement ce qui s'est produit
[Musique]
d'ailleurs